hello everybody my name is Mark Martin
what what duh where's the ground what
what audience what are you doing looking
at the ground oh hey how's it going
everybody we're a murder hi Bob
all right I didn't say hi to you dick I
might like say hey oh yeah wow look at
that
we found Wade you're no longer a pile of
sand that's so cool what would you like
donkey for a while - yeah well I don't
know if that one's could have showed the
light of day I've got a question if that
one should go if you know whatever we're
talking about it wasn't a donkey but the
main I bet we'll find out well they
already know by the time they'll see
this belly to be who donkey
I have no idea what you guys are that's
cuz that's you were you were you're
missing yeah okay Oh oh we found you you
were up here I know what wait hang on
what's this magical creature floating
off to the side here oh boy he's gone
disappeared
that's just concerning so I have to
battle that I don't know it's probably
dangerous but anyway hey Charlie hi
[ __ ]
hey shy guys shut up what what happens
if I do this what where are you
um wait here such a piece of [ __ ] what
why'd why why'd you do that your son
about oh no help it and do [ __ ] die
you're no hell Kuwait this wait this all
feel horrible start
why not dead Bob I'm not doing that Bob
where are you I see you down there how
do i Oh what my do I see you down there
Oh way you ruin everything
didn't break your glass okay so while
they're down there I'm gonna do my
introduction we are playing of the
continuation of our previous castaway
and I'm once again delinking dildo
drinking a delicious amaretto sour I
don't like a gigantic half liter arrows
are I'm still tracking angling in honor
of the departed wait even though he's
back now
no idea what you were drinking last time
so that's pretty cool for you so anyway
in Skyblock we're given a terribly small
island I don't know why we didn't do
this before because it's so much better
than our last castaway idea then again
there aren't rivers of lava around us so
we need to go from this island to that
island over there so and nobody asked
but I've got a Bud Light Lime in ice
cream that's cuz no one cares about it
sounds so gross you think it is but it's
actually pretty much big it is and it
really is yeah wait a bob was doing a
much better Rick than you ever could
wait who's due up actually voices the
entire cast of The Walking Dead he does
he's very talented okay specially in
three episodes of this show I have you
know never built like I've never built a
cobblestone generator before but I'm
gonna do it and I'm gonna do it right no
one touch the tree hang on I'm gonna
chop down the tree you gotta wait hang
on you got to make like a hole or
something then when you put the lava
here it'll melt that water and then we
get cobble start it it didn't melt the
water
I don't even break the ice no wait there
we go yeah ah everybody high-five my
webcam not mine and only mine not anyone
elses in three two one oh damn it haha
yeah I'm so great now just watch as I
dig out this cobblestone quit taking
forever everything's ruined and it turns
into obsidian probably probably
cobblestone without it going on oh oh oh
let's put the with the hole here oh I'm
supposed to put all there so it doesn't
go oh huh well I almost have never done
this before you shut up
wait [ __ ] as well look uh dad [ __ ] out
ha
ah okay how do we reset this sumbitch I
don't know you Highland anyway
reset I must remove all players wait
hang on there's another bucket of lava
in here I'm gonna hang on wait I got a
magical bucket of Island or a magical
bucket of water appeared in my inventory
it's like grant it's fun amazing ok here
we try the skin OOP oh man now it works
ah yeah how about that sure everything
won't be ruined when you try and wait
what are you doing wait what you doing
there digging what are you doing there
would you guys not want to expand
they're staying down here there's sand
why is there sand who needs sand we have
a cactus you got to grow your own cactus
and cactus only grows on sand wait a
minute I didn't get anything we need
Haemon I'm gonna I'm gonna dig out to
this island over here so you guys
actually wait I have an idea a good
expand the the cobblestone generator and
so that there's a collection underneath
it how does that work the cobblestone
falls out the bottom I don't think
that'll work cuz then the wall in the
water no the water won't oh the water in
the lava will still touch they just
touch as they're about to flow down
right so if we put a hole a hole in a
collect on now jump in the water
the water water Bob pushing me in the
hole oh I'm horrible okay so what we
need to do is we need to get wood out of
this thing so I'm gonna break down the
tree and you can't stop me I'm doing it
but wait you gotta break the leaves
doing it no you go like the leaves died
natural cuz they get more saplings that
way and it sucks cuz it's gonna land
right in the lava some of them maybe or
I feel like this you feel like what hey
that's an idea no I'm not looking at you
wait hang on what what I built dirt on
top of the lava oh that's not a bad idea
oh now that idea sucks ass I should have
thought of it first just like your
mother
hey now that's your mother don't we're
gonna get the whole internet in on into
your mom jokes you know that right you
think you will but probably okay so
everyone who's watching this right now
we have this running joke in our group
of friends Oh God
everyone anytime there's a your mom joke
it's always about Wade's mom like no
matter what Wade says no matter what way
does there's always a having sex with
your mom Jeff and we tried to get this
done before but you guys didn't
understand it quite well enough it's
about it's not Wade's momma's fat it's
about having sex with Wade's mom oh ha
oh I didn't get anything still see it's
broken hey Bob hold on so everyone out
there write in the comments below the
most creative oh wait why I didn't
realize the lava was right there that
was my bad wave stop being a dumbass
down there again let me try this again
what are you doing bub I'm carving the
cobblestone from underneath here to see
if I can catch it did we do this wrong
that it's not working
see it makes another one behind we
harvest it can you only harvest
cobblestone with the pickaxe in this or
something no I don't think so
hang on I'm gonna make some wood and to
make I'm gonna make a workbench and then
I'm gonna make sticks and then we're
gonna get that I probably shouldn't used
up all our cobblestone on that little
no-step warts
go go grab some of that cobblestone
because we need that or something I
don't know I don't know unless you what
happen this uh-huh wha with what with
what Bob I'm standing on top of the
cobblestone to harvest it this time yeah
that's a good idea well I didn't die but
I'd get it either hang on let me I'm in
a Miss I got a I got a wooden pickaxe
just let me let me at it let me okay if
you stand on top of it and harvest
you'll fall straight through and
hopefully you'll catch it wait there it
is I saw it it popped out hang on I got
alright you just throw this dirt
why can't you only harvest it with a
pickaxe what doesn't make any sense at
all why did this hole get filled in I
don't know this does this is all dumb I
was I collector will still work Wade
what the wide what who broke that rock
dad that was me but okay nevermind then
no it's just going right in a llama this
game sucks okay no try now did you get
yeah I got one okay we have to do it
like that then it's got it's got to come
up okay
[ __ ] I just broke the dirt underneath it
we need the coordination yeah
after this stupid-ass cobblestone to not
go to the left right into the love it's
almost as if it wants to die this is
really sad
can I pick up the lava and raise the
lava 1 mm oh I got that one I don't
think I don't think that would work wait
I don't I don't think that would work so
what are you guys doing to help out our
Skyblock situation here how are we gonna
get off the island I just extended dirt
beneath it so easier to get to the cops
i sha mark what lava spreads out right
yeah what if we move the lava one
farther away from the water what Fe
tubes to spread out I don't know would
that work
can we try it yeah you try that mmm
okay was dying do you have the bucket
mark cuz I need the bucket to do this I
don't have ya here hangs take that
bucket this doesn't work hangout [ __ ] on
you hang the F on okay there see if that
house it didn't help [ __ ] because it
still goes down it goes down more than
it goes left or up not whatever if we
can't with it fell down and filled out
yeah exactly it fell down that's what we
need but then it fell to the left right
there right into the lava and then it
fell into the lava again you [ __ ]
outta soda
I swear to go out and fill down that
time okay swear to God into the lava
right into the [ __ ] lava this is
never happened I've seen people do
mother of god there's a bull this is
bull good back down there there's
cobblestone just - I'm not what sapling
I got Bob it's so silently - I didn't
mean to hurt I hit you sorry it happens
you were in the way there's another one
alright I got it
how many cobblestone are we up to now I
have six I have five this guy's great
this is a
labour-intensive system I think doesn't
it's not supposed to do this it's not I
got all right I guess got those last two
so it's like coming it's coming together
now wait hang on I have an idea this
probably should have been done a long
time ago what if I stand by the
cobblestone like this Oh would it magnet
to me OOP got it Oh
son of them ha ha OOP got it Oh this
would have been so much easier a long
time ago right ah still got it bid all
right all right out right out right
that's working then go learn to die you
gonna learn today aah what just exploded
took away dirt block you got you went
into berserk mode why did you go to Dirk
mode oh I have a sapling oh I got a
plant the sapling Oh
spread some dirt around here take this
dirt take that Dart
I gave you dirt though Bob no put on the
edge no we're gonna build around it with
what I have a bunch of dirt in my yes Oh
got a plan oh there's certain this is
from the engine has to be like is this
ok I think it has to be surrounded by
grad dirt
I believe so that's fine edge well then
we should know we have any more water
you love Laurie but you don't have one
ice here you don't need water for trees
I don't think I mastic week we could
make another cobblestone thing
how much cobblestone do we need we just
need to go over to the other Island
write as much as we can get though right
I guess well if I just stay here and
keep mining for a while then it should
here I'll make one and I'll do it I'll
do it also do you have more lava yeah
there's another bucket of lava in there
oh cool all right done wait what are you
doing rest or nothing or a farm a farm
I'm gonna be growing trees I'm gonna try
to build something to cover the
mushrooms we get mushrooms growing
mushrooms we don't have anymore have you
don't even looked in the chest I bought
I got the lob out that's all I care
about and then I stopped listening to
you as soon as this piece of jet drunk
minecraft started
you're like the dumbest person I know
quick vote who's the dumbest person you
know everybody out there and what's with
these at once they don't know it either
any of us I'm taking all the food I've
got all the food just saying and I'm
gonna go I'm gonna go to this other
Island I'm gonna make it I like the work
I got all the fasten what you like the
worst kind of pasen pasen pasen pasen
pasen pasen pasen you know like a person
a passin ya pasen pasen yak i like the
way you say over rum room the thing you
sleep in your bed rum who says bedroom I
don't know what how do you say ruin rum
rum rum rum rum rum rum rum rum market
mmm
okay hang on my bedroom room that's cuz
I go fast in my bedroom
ha ha ha ha that's not good ha ha
I rub up my rev up the engines in my
bedroom that sounds a little bit ha ha
ha ha
you didn't even need that ice because
there was a the water would have flowed
didn't flow I try and I was playing with
it the whole time you didn't do it right
um I didn't do what right you didn't do
the water right obviously you have some
problems
RORO homerooms shut up Scooby no I guess
a crap roll
yeah that's right go back in your corner
and I get a pickaxe is that possible I
have let's see I have enough marques all
the wood yeah if you have enough glue do
we make a pickaxe oh yeah I can make a
cut here I'll make you a cobblestone one
Oh be careful though but what it in the
chest don't throw it at me Oh Oh God uh
I threw it at you who you a piece of
[ __ ] you got it
don't be angry I am angry you are angry
how angry are you very angry shut
Scooby no one gives a crap rear honoree
we what we're on a River Rhine read what
the hell are you talking Bob what's he
saying look I don't know girls a tree Oh
a tree rock good god man what's wrong
with you reap replica work together to
survive this is the only way we're gonna
make it off this island as if we
cooperate so for your scooby oh if
you're Scooby that means
Bob's shaggy like totally make your
Villa I'm Velma I want I was gonna say I
was Velma
I wouldn't mind me and Velma huh sorry I
need some cobblestone to build around
these trees shut up no you don't wait
you want some wait why do you need
cobblestone to build around this trap
whatever I cut down the tree the leaves
don't we don't lose sapling don't you
just get more dirt I don't want to waste
our dirt cuz dirt can grow the trees
whereas cobble Konami well if you're
spreading the dirt then you can put more
trees there yes but we only have looted
amounts of dirt so if I put dirt with
cobble around it we can max oh we're
using the dirt I think you're stupid and
your ideas are dumb and your face is
ugly where'd my lava go what uh [ __ ]
where my lava go huh wait hang on if I
get enough cobblestone I'll make a
venture out to that other Island I'll
get whatever supplies I bet they have
some lava and we'll be able to do
everything I'll harvest all of their
dirt my guys give me the combo sure sir
monsters fires oh [ __ ] oh my god oh no a
word oh hang on I'll make us swords or
Gerudo just fill the wall stupids what
fun we got to go over there give me two
give me two cobblestone and I'll fix it
what no we got to go over to there yeah
not right now
Oh oh yeah they'll burn up in the okay
all right oh oh
oh shut up just because you got that
higher education and whatnot doesn't
mean you're better than me of shaggy
I mean jinkies
jinkies shaggy ha ha I'm the smart one
why am i way hang on Hil I gotta get my
role right rise okay yeah wave you do
your shaggy or you do your Ruby hey
Scoob let's get back to the mystery van
no do your Scooby are rowdy jinkies like
totally scoops like totally scoob's oh
no I got a bad feeling about this one
scoob's i just want to smoosh also fat
man I'm jonesing real bad boobs
why is cobble stone falling down because
it's going with that man yeah I'll put
that back
thanks jig brand attack brick bread
right Rock Run right Oh Joey's jinkies
scoob's wait no that's all right remove
those partl oh shut up Meatwad oh boy
Oh monomer yo mama or the role model ah
yo mama's busy with Jessie don't walk
mark how much trouble you have I have 28
pieces do you want to give me that and
I'll venture out once these guys burn up
all right I'm trusting you on this one
you want to sword - uh no oh look
without I'm just gonna let see if they
die too bad I'm making a sword the
creeper won't die that's for sure
you can hopefully just push him off push
your money to try and angle them off the
catch it's right there behind you it's
on that block there you got it okay
get inside me sword Hey ya see if I can
edge battle this dude mmm are you gonna
make it and hanging what are you looking
at
there's a guy right well it's just a
it's just a Skellington I mean it's just
a pumpkin
Rud Brandon root and Ryan no just break
down the top block here and then you
could hit it oh never mind then all
right you do what you want I'm gonna
keep drinking hey I got bone meal well I
got a bone huh
I bathe we could insta grow trees he'll
bet that's good oh let's go to stuff ah
all right I cleared it off that was easy
wait do a combination of shaggy Scooby
and Velma Ricky Ricky's I just wanna
smoke some marriage you owner
well I sound like Hershel I just went to
pay for her resting your honor whoo oh I
wanna smoke some marijuana the hill is
rearing to get back to the wrister ear I
think reread I don't know I can't do
Scooby
how do you do Scooby ha ha Louie do it
will you do it for a Scooby Snack Roger
a wrapper one you do it for Raph one
what rival grasp you have a what all
right crisp we're like 20 blocks away
still really shy so I've got wait hang
on I got 17 wait how many blocks of
cobble do you have roar ha ha ha ha ha
roar oh you're wasting our precious dirt
over here huh how could you all right
let's see if this will make it I may be
trying to get to a whole island of dirt
right yes you know I guess I guess
you're right
oh by the way I've got all of the food
every all food you're such a piece of sh
o if I die well we're kind of oh we're
so close I rot roar roar we're so close
get over there get over the Wade are you
still doing the Scooby thing brass rod
room jump yeah I'll chop ya maybe we
made it yeah there's a slight jump but
our own rubber wrapper room how many how
many do you need
cuz I'm mining some no we got it we're
already here I'm already harvesting the
Train I'm gonna get all the dirt what I
thought you said you had to jump yeah we
had to jump one block oh and then we got
cobblestone from this thing and we're
ready here so I'm just gonna collect all
the dirt and then we're gonna get out of
here hey where are you I'm over on the
other Island I'm just gonna drink I'm
just gonna stand here and drink you guys
I was trying to combine blue rod with
the stirrer rock do meet buzz meet Ron
Ronnie gosh Smeagol scooby shaggy Velma
do it see it just devolves into Hershel
after a while it just that's all it does
you know people probably watch this and
be like Hershel that doesn't sound a
tiger get out walk out some kind of
ragged monster ha ha ha I'm pretty good
that's pretty good did pretty good wait
that makes you hit that makes me hate
you just a little less now Ripple's rip
ease rip ease what are you saying run
right run a wind browner
gone with the wind is that what you said
gone like the wind the hills are alive
with our signs lead Hawks Trina rowr ads
oh you walked into me while I was
digging oh whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa okay
we're gonna have a respectable home
after this aren't you all happy ah
reward robust oh crap are we gonna get
straighted here we would we would oh
[ __ ] I'm so sorry
hang on is easily fixable it's not a big
deal haha I'm just gonna drink more
screw you guys I'm just wait are you
trying it what are you doing real more
that is tastiest ever notice how I've
had ever ever ever ever
it's cuz you've had so much I've already
had half a liter of it so mmm-hmm I got
a bunch of goodies I got a bunch of dirt
I'm gonna just start expanding our whole
thing did we get the lava from that one
yeah I got I got the whole chest I'm
moving it over cool you're the best Bob
I love you s Chris hate you way o our
trees in a cloud is that bad
probably I think it means instant death
for everyone I'm going to allow you and
me this with oh and read this roughen
but rambles
you and me baby Ryan nothing but ramble
show a good G key fob you haven't done
any combination voices you try you try
umm you trust some be pirate Herschel
you do zombie pirate zombie I don't have
a Herschel you don't outdo your Herschel
Oh Bobby I always go to vests here mark
mark mark stand still okay
skadoosh skadoosh ooh more dirt thank
you
punch Moria we're gonna have like a
whole home here um there's gonna be
great we can live together and then
sleep together and then have babies
together all right
what yeah you know maybe just maybe
maybe Oh babies maybe maybe maybe I
don't know I'm just I'm throwing things
out there I'm just I'm just saying
things you know could be could not be
maybe I'm joking I'm just feeling the
water I'm just dreaming for our eventual
survival oh whoops
whoa whoa whoa what the hell happened
who did that Roo didn't want don't want
just oh that was me yeah whoops you you
berserk term I just destroyed the lava
peril I got the sand and more dirt hey
wait hold on the cobbler is too cool
I just covered it I call rap just cool
out dude damn hang on I'm trying now we
can't kill ourselves with well-pressed
cobblestone generators oh I did there
yes all the lavas covered in [ __ ] yes I
saw so let's start making farms you me
bard me QB Berta what was lost my voice
hi zombie pirate Hershel
honeypot do it do it I don't even I
don't even know what Herschel would say
I honestly have only seen two episodes
of that show you know honestly over from
all what we've done I don't know what
Herschel says or sounds like I've seen
all the episodes ah oh hang on
huh something's gonna come out of my
mouth ah it's time for you to take
charge of the group Rick
um Herschel me I can't do it
no that was good keep going all right
show me some good pirate Herschel I'll
be back argh
yeah argh argh
um stone I can do that Oh
what does Herschel say anyway ah I'm
pretty sure all he says is I'm Herschel
they saw ha ha ha ha ha I'm Herschel
Baker all the group Rick so it cuz he's
not this southern drawl in an old man
boys he's like oh he speaks like no home
girl I'm saying your song Oh Elvis Elvis
Virgil that was a thousand ZZ Top Oh
Suzy Z topper shil
uh how's that Oh sugar also uh Marshall
oh ok never do that again
zombie pirate Elvis Herschel hang on
zombie pirate wait no do Bill Clinton
Herschel oh I'm gonna touch you sorry
sorry
really that was your go-to thing oh I'm
gonna touch you oh is that Bill Clinton
know what bill couldn't sounds like
that's what he said he's way too smooth
to say something like that
jeez has him class I'm gonna touch you
in your jacket really that's what you
think that's what you think let's smooth
that's what you think really no wonder
you can't get any girls Wade
geez no wonder your shadow alone and
have no one to love in your sorry wait
I'm just projecting my problem where do
we the + evil laugh ever way to be a
supporting friend dick you're welcome
so what's that more after you're sad I'm
wait that was the best impression we've
done yet that was alright have we done
anything I think we stopped being
productive like 10 minutes ago put put
30 cobblestone in the chest and no good
and we've got three empty buckets I
guess what do we do now what's the isn't
there a list of challenges if you type
slay away hang on challenge okay Apple
collector what the hell is an Apple
collector you have to get out like you
can get apples from the tree okay well
what is it I do though I park mark mark
mark
look where I'm looking huh is that Oh
what over there what that what there's
an island over there with like a house
on it I don't see anything all up wait
do you see oh my god yeah oh wait no I
see it the clouds are in the way the
clouds are are we supposed to get there
well we got a climb man we do person as
a dedicated cobblestone dick let me make
up this bridge back do we need this
bridge anymore
well I don't know I don't think so but I
don't know how you're gonna I'm cheap
speech in mind the edge and and try and
collect it good luck I don't think
that's gonna work though I'm not
bringing anything with me cuz I'm
probably gonna die yes please do I mean
don't I mean you're not Wade I don't
want you to die
well I'm stuck here with Wade oh oh [ __ ]
we're out of time we've been over time
ah [ __ ] Nikes well man I guess what to
continue yes there will be another part
of castaway don t don don don don don
don don don don
so anyway bob has a twitter wait has a
youtube channel
lord minion seven seven seven check him
out that's a really stupid name but
whatever so thank you all so much he's
got Settlers of Catan like lots of it
let this yeah if you love so know
there's a spider haha oh sorry Bob I got
alright I'd light and Butterfinger don't
go so well together yeah neither to
Settlers of Catan and YouTube who are
something like that I don't know inside
why so much demand for more of that it's
ridiculous have you died more sir that's
why put it out put it out okay thank you
panic over okay so thank you all so much
for watching click the annotation for
more videos that we've done and as
always well we'll see you in the next
video
by
whoa